thank you for calling i i greatly
appreciated when was the first time
you laid eyes on zach wilson coach
well i i was a defense coordinator at
the university of utah summer camp
and he was about fifth grade and um
you know like you can always recognize
the the great athletes even when they're
little
and he kind of just stood out there's a
group of them that did and
i just kind of followed him and then you
know we're fortunate enough when i got
the head coaching job here at byu to
to recruit him and uh really thankful
that he was able to come here and
throw the rock for us and then obviously
had a great season last year and that
was
pretty much the first time that he's
been 100 healthy and so i think
right now it's just scratching the
surface on the on the things that he can
do on the football field
so you know when you said fifth grade
i've been around the block a few times
in the nfl and around the
world of football i thought am i missing
just a type of uh like star
rating when you so so you're saying he
was you're saying fifth grade like
between fourth and sixth grade
like like like that like he's nine years
old
yeah he pretty much when you mean i mean
he he was i thought he was a great
athlete back then and then you just
you you see these kids you know i i
remember startled to lay when he was a
great
d lyman same same thing you just see
these guys when they're when they're
obviously uh further along and
definitely there's some guys that that
develop faster and
than others but you just kind of notice
the things that he did as an athlete it
just
his football iq and the fact that he
loved playing on the field
that was the best part of his his day
was being out there
playing football and he played both
sides it wasn't just like
just the quarterback and that was all
but the guy's a great athlete he can do
a lot of
different things he plays point guard on
his high school
basketball team so he's got tons of
athleticism he can dunk out the gym and
and
he just knew that there was something
special about him but when you get to
talk to him and get to meet him in
person and
sit around him you start to realize that
football is what this guy loves the most
that's his passion and i imagine he's
going to make a living out of it
even when he's done playing he's going
to i think he's going to be a phenomenal
coach if that's what he wants to go into
and
he's got a great charisma i think he's
got he's got he's at the total package
and
i think you know i'm excited and honored
that i was able to coach him
well i do look forward to getting a
chance to chat with him uh between now
and the draft
um and i just love you know stories of
journeys and things of that nature and
so when you did
uh recruit him for byu did you basically
say hello again and say i saw you when
you were in fifth grade or did he
remember
i mean what was that like uh when you
finally got a chance to get him
um potentially to byu when you were
recruiting him
well you know his his dad was a former
player at utah
and you just kind of you you you always
know the names and you see guys at camps
every year yeah
and different camps and you see them you
know as they go throughout from
middle school to to high school and
you know he was actually committed to
boise early and uh we came in late i
came in late recruiting and then
uh lucky for us it wasn't too late you
know and then he was able to
you know change his commitment and come
to byu and and the rest is history and
that
the only unfortunate part for me is that
i don't get him back for another year
i'm really excited for him and he's got
he's got a great future and i think
i was hoping he'd come back but
definitely this is a great move for him
and i'm excited for
him and his family and his hard work and
sacrifices start to pay off and
once you get to talk to him and just sit
down talk ball you'll realize
everything that i'm talking about it's
hard to see on film but
um you know he he just has the it factor
i've said it over and over and over
again to
so many different people and i just he
belongs in that league and i'm excited
for him and whatever team
drafts him kalani sataki the head coach
of byu football here on the rich eisen
show
you know i'm from new york city sir and
i know jet fans are particularly excited
when they see
when you say you know film there's been
a lot of his film that has been
on social media and shared i can
guarantee you being from new york that
most jet fans have not seen a quarter
let alone a full game
of byu football pretty much to be very
honest with you
so what would they be getting in zack
wilson what would a team be getting in
zack wilson you talked about him being a
gamer
what has he been like in terms of
adversity facing adversity and facing
the heat
that you've seen coach that's his that's
his whole that's his whole
general makeup in football uh
under-recruited
and he should have been a big-time
recruit and uh didn't get a lot of
recognition
kind of a late bloomer especially in in
his in his
height and his growth but i think he
started starting to put things together
towards his senior year and a lot of
times recruiting takes place so much
earlier than that
um and then and then when he got here he
came in as a true freshman and competed
for a starting spot and earned that spot
mid-season and he wasn't completely all
healthy but the guy graduated early from
high school didn't even
play basketball he decided to put that
to the side and come here and
join byu in the spring and play spring
football so he can compete for a
starting spot
he got the spot um you know he battled a
little bit of injury
his freshman sophomore year and there's
mostly just because the guy has been
so active and playing so many different
sports uh
once he got the surgeries and got things
fixed and got healthy uh you could see
him just take off from there and
this was the you know we had a well when
he did get hurt he we had to
had a quarterback controversy and had
some had a
competition going on and he was all for
it the guy loves to compete
and and if he doesn't get the spot he's
a great support for the team
he's a great teammate to have a great
leader and you know once
once he was able to get that spot back
uh you saw
what he could do on on the field and i
think
you get to see the things that he does i
think work ethic is the key
nobody is as confident as he is going
into a game
because he puts in more time off the
field studies tons of film he works late
hours like the coaches do
he loves watching film he watches nfl
film he watches everything and
comes up with a lot of different plays
he's always recommending plays he's a
he's a coach's dream but also a
nightmare because he's like hey how
about this play
you know how about this one i like this
one and and and a lot of it is great
ideas and then you have to just kind of
figure out that it it works towards his
his
his skill set and so the sky's the limit
for the guy and i can't wait to
see what he does in the nfl when it's
just full time that he's had to kind of
balance it with with school here you
know but it's a hard academic school at
byu is and
now he's just all full-time ball and
i've talked to him and text him and
the guy is just excited now because he's
a full-time football player
well it sure looks like he's just
shooting up draft boards right now
and that uh the situation with the jets
what they're gonna do with darnold and
what might happen with desean watson i
mean there's a lot
of dominoes in play here that might wind
up with zach wilson in new york
or with somebody else second overall um
when you said the nfl film watching what
are you talking about
what what is he what does he look like
he watches coach he watches
all kinds of film on his off time while
guys are playing video games
and playing their ps5 and stuff like
that he's on his ipad and his set and
his
laptop watching film he you can talk to
our video coordinator he downloads nfl
film so he's watching
patrick mahomes aaron rodgers
roethlisberger
he's watching all these guys and i mean
like tons of film and then he'll
text me and say hey i like this play
what do you think
and it's like yeah man whatever you like
let's just take a look at it and
you know he just loves football and
that's what he's about and
and i think he's in the right setting
now and and it makes a lot of sense why
he's
he's skyrocketing because people are
actually talking to him
it's not like this is just happening out
of nothing
people that know what they're talking
about in football are sitting down and
talking ball with him
and they're coming away impressed and
that's just talking to him in person
when they see him throw i think he's
gonna
he's gonna back it all up but i can tell
you one thing because he loves football
he's such a great support in the team in
the position room
he'll figure it out i mean he wasn't the
starter right away he's a true freshman
he sat there and supported his teammates
and then when it was time for him to
take the to take the reins
mid way through the season he was able
to fly with it and that's just how he
works and then when
we disrupted it because of injury and we
said hey we have to open up the
quarterback competition he didn't he
didn't feel entitled for anything he
said let's go to work man let's do it
and it was pretty evident right away
that that he was up for the competition
so if you want a guy that's going to
work hard
get along with all his teammates not
think not feel entitled or anything then
you're going to get the right
right guy and whether it's the jets or
whoever drafts him
i think they're going to get a great
player do you have a good example coach
sataki of of
him saying let's try this play and then
you're like okay take a look at it and
then it actually happened in a game and
uh it resulted in yeah one something one
comes to mind is it's the houston
uh is a houston um screenplay
that we've he flipped the ball like
underhand flipped it in the red zone
against houston and he got that from
patrick mahomes did it then we
i mean we called it the chiefs play you
know so that's
one play and if i mean you can it's it's
documented you can kind of look it up
and see what he does but
there's a lot of those plays that he
just really likes and
you know football there's like nobody
has a a
a stamp on everything nobody has a
monopoly on all the plays so
uh when you have a guy that just loves
football and loves all these plays
and and he sees what he can work on but
he does all these different throws
he he's a big fan of all the
quarterbacks i mean i think a big part
of
his excitement going to the nfl is that
he gets to see these quarterbacks
after the the game and kind of connect
with him and talk to him
like he just likes that he if you were
if you allow him
the time to do it he would just sit
there and pick the brain of all the
great quarterbacks
we we have steve young and other alumni
that have played here byu
that keep in touch with him and he's
he's always talking ball with those guys
and
john beck is one of his trainers so sure
and you know myself and our office
coordinator he's always staying in touch
with all these guys and
then it's all ball man the guy loves
ball and that's what he wants to talk
about that's what he wants to live and
live with and and now he's in it so um
his vacation would be probably go to
somewhere sunny sit on the beach and
watch football
film kalani sataki byu head football
coach here on the rich eisen show let's
talk about you and your program just a
little bit here if you don't mind
so it's coveted 19 your your
your schedule gets totally exploded
because so many of the teams that you
might be playing against say we're
going to only stick in our conference
you have if i'm not mistaken just three
games left you
cobble together a schedule you go 11-1
you develop a quarterback that may be
the second overall pick
in the draft and yet there's still so
much conversation about
the power five conferences if you will
taking their ball and creating their own
world what do you say about that
possibility coach
hey we were just really thankful that we
got to play football
and then so i i don't know the uh all
the politics and everything involved in
it i have a group of guys that love the
game of football
and they're very appreciative of all the
people that made it happen last year
so we're just going to keep playing this
game
just full of gratitude and appreciation
for those that make it happen
and and you know we're really thankful
for the teams that step up and want to
play us and
we have a schedule now in 2021 that
we're excited about and
we've been in situations where we've
played some really tough games against
p5 teams but as they were allowed to see
it allowed us to see where we can do it
and how we can improve and
get better depth-wise but i'm not going
to get into all the
you know we deserve this type of stuff i
i just know that these guys love
football
they want to play and they appreciate
the fact that the others are making it
happen for them so
uh the conversations that you're you're
asking probably is more for our a.d and
our administration but
i'll let them handle in the meantime i'm
enjoying just coaching guys at love ball
i love that that's great that said i i
do i'm
fascinated because i was sitting here in
this chair watching the season unfold
do you think any teams ducked you this
year given the opportunity hey you're
like hey
you love ball let's play ball and then
teams were saying we need someone to
play and you raise your hand
and maybe they didn't want any piece of
you do you think that happened this year
coach no listen i i i i get to know a
lot of these coaches
in so many different conferences and in
different schools and they're all you
don't you don't coach football if you're
going to duck away from competition so
none of them want to do that the problem
is that you have to work through
all these different you know the
conferences make these statements and
they make these restrictions
so these teams can't play but if you
allow just the coaches to make the
decision
i guarantee you everybody would play
more football and they would allow it to
happen so
uh never ever do i think that a team
would ever duck us because
they don't i mean that's just when
you're a competitor you want to play the
best
it doesn't matter who it is and i i've
met all these coaches and
all these players on the field i mean
let me just give you an example we have
guys that
train all year round for literally maybe
two minutes of straight football
that they get to play the whole entire
season and then and then we get to play
against people that make that sacrifice
and so
when you have people they're very
similar in
in the way that they think they're all
competitors so all the coaches out there
like to compete all the players like to
compete
it's just all the restrictions that the
conferences or
the schools may put them in into but
never would ever
think that a coach or team is ever
ducking anyone
all right and then i do want to give you
this opportunity before i send you back
into your
your monday is i'm clearly calling up
about zach wilson i'm fascinated by him
and his rise is ascension and
what a crucial um player he's going to
be in this upcoming nfl draft i'm sure
you have some others
that are available you want to pound the
table for them a little bit before i let
you go today yeah we got a lot of
we have a lot of great players i mean we
have three guys that are coming
out early you know for the nfl draft
that declared early and and
um you know dax mill is our receiver
that you saw
zach throw into a lot and brady
christensen is our left tackle
all three of those guys came out a year
early and and and
uh i'm happy for them and their
opportunities we have a lot of great
players that are
on the verge of getting drafted and a
lot of great alignment and i think we're
gonna
this is gonna be a good start for us
funneling people into the nfl and
i think the nfl needs a lot of guys from
byu there you know it's been
really good in the past yes and
hopefully we can keep this train rolling
and you was your when you were when you
were in the nfl
uh for that one year coach uh before you
got hurt
dick lebeau was he your first head coach
in the nfl was he the guy there yeah the
bengals yeah
and i mean it was it it didn't even get
really started right but
i just love the fact that um football
it's inevitable unless you're tom brady
that football will probably end
and there's one you won't like the
timing of it all you know and that's
just the rest of us not
not everybody can have the tom brady
effect but um and when it did end for me
i just needed to be around it and and
luckily it
turned me to coaching and so i i'm just
really honored to be in the football
life and to be doing this for a living
and being connected with so many great
people
coach really appreciate the time thank
you for the insight
um congrats on the great season and best
of luck moving on let's let's chat again
appreciate it appreciate it rich thank
you you bet that is coach kalani sataki
of byu football
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here